early in the pandemic it was predicted
that divorce would
surge due to the stressors of quarantine
but it has been
the complete opposite the united states
divorce rate has hit a 50-year low and
here to explain the why
and how covid is affecting our
relationships
is mental health and fitness expert
lacey alderson
lacey thank you so much for joining us
today does this sharp decline mean that
couples are just happier in lockdown
than expected or
are they staying together for other
reasons well first of all what a giant
surprise i don't think any of us saw
this coming to see the numbers going
this way but
it's a little bit of both mercedes you
definitely have people that
were able to spend more time with their
spouse and really
like reconnect if you will but then
there was also a lot of polls being done
and 58
of both men and women did admit that
they had a greater sense of appreciation
for their mate
during covid so being together more
is actually helping our relationships
and i think a lot of people like i said
never would have thought that but can
you believe that that's the case the
more time we are spending together the
more we are appreciating
connecting and being more visible with
our mate and seeing them in their daily
role
and appreciating what they're bringing
to the table that maybe we hadn't
noticed before
now let's talk about children and what
their role is in couples staying
together is that a major factor
you know what couples with children it's
always been a factor obviously with with
children you never want to break up a
family but now you have these aspects of
homeschooling and schools are closed and
daycares are closed and
people are thinking wait a second if i
was going to have joint custody
really what would it look like and how
would my role change
with these new restrictions being placed
upon my children and their day-to-day
activities
definitely something to think about also
a lot of people lost their jobs during
this time and
do unemployment rates and lack of money
coming in does that
play a role in the lack of divorces i
mean i'm not going to
beat around the bush divorce is
expensive it's expensive to begin with
and then we add this factor of
unemployment and
how are we going to deal with the
settlement that would come in i mean you
don't really know what's going on with
the business
and sometimes it's a family business on
top of it so finances aren't just the
basic finances of divorce but really
what that settlement and
what the entire family would look like
with these new restrictions in place as
well
so it could really just be a pause in
divorce because of the finances
associated with this
is it basically one of those situations
where time will tell
as soon as this pandemic is over i have
to be completely transparent mercedes
time will absolutely
well we appreciate your knowledge and
great
information lacey thank you so much las
vegas now we'll be right back